dès demain tout le territoire à
l'exception de mayotte et de la guyane
où le virus circule encore activement
tout le territoire donc passera dans ce
qu'il est désormais convenu d'appeler la
zone verte ce qui permettra notamment
une reprise plus forte du travail et la
réouverture des cafés et restaurants en
ile de france
dès demain il sera à nouveau possible de
se déplacer entre les pays européens et
à partir du 1er juillet nous pourrons
nous rendre dans les états hors d'europe
où l'épidémie sera maîtrisée dès demain
en hexagone comme en outre-mer les
crèches les écoles les collèges se
prépareront à accueillir à partir du 22
juin
tous les élèves de manière obligatoire
et selon les règles de présence normal
il faudra continuer d'éviter au maximum
lé rassemblement car nous savons qu'ils
sont les principales occasions de
propagation du virus
ils resteront donc très encadrée le
second tour des élections municipales
pourra se dérouler dans les communes
concernées le 28 juin
enfin pour nos aînés en maison de
retraite ou en établissement les visites
devront désormais être autorisé